germaris apparemment votre petite
entreprise ne connaît pas la crise et
son plan sexuel comment ça va très bien
ça va très très bien les leaders malgré
tout c'est oui je le dis d'ailleurs dans
le spectacle du projet d les
éjaculations sont moins forte au départ
ouais parce que cod 26 pts le premier
jet côté côté jeunes des fois tu arrives
à te le mettre dans le bain après en
vissant tartan même du ve puis après
tout simplement l'époque sur la basket
c'est sûr le goût en plastique de la
basket époque j'en ai entendu
laisse-toi pénétré par l'idée
jean marie bigard des films star donc on
va faire l'interview alain delon a